c'était il y a deux ans à peine pour
justin trudeau
tous les espoirs étaient permis une
visite officielle en chine et même des
pourparlers de libre échange
mais depuis la relation entre les deux
pays s'est rapidement envenimée nos
exportations ont diminué l'année passée
l'investissement direct étranger de la
chine vers canada a diminué aussi et
maintenant deux tiers des canadiens ont
une vision négative sur la chine
l'arrestation de la dirigeante de huawei
même wenzhou au canada à la demande des
américains a tout fait dérailler les
chinois ont riposté et arrêté deux
canadiens la situation est une priorité
pour le canada le gouvernement trudeau
est pris dans un étau et ses leviers
sont limitées pas question cependant de
faire un échange de prisonniers le
canada est un état de droit il le
processus d'extradition suivra son cours
affirme la vice première ministre
on sait que l'apache ii le gouvernement
9 à ottawa
la pression monte l'opposition demande
des comptes à la force et la formation
d'un comité parlementaire s'est penché
sur les relations canada chine le nouvel
ambassadeur canadien en chine dominique
martin sera convoquée d'ici le 7 février
comment stabiliser les relations entre
les deux pays le canada doit-il hausse
élite on y revient de durcir vous poser
la question quel est l'impact réel on
peut avoir sur la chaîne grandiose sans
la position sanctions économiques
mesures ciblées envers des dirigeants
chinois
jusqu'où le canada pourrait-il aller
pour exprimer son mécontentement
prudence disent les experts d'importants
intérêts économiques sont en jeu nous
sommes un petit pays contre le deuxième
plus grand pays du monde qui a la plus
de contribution à la croissance
économique mondiale
déjà des embargos chinois sur la viande
et le canola canadien ont fait souffrir
nos agriculteurs
selon cet expert le canada doit miser
sur l'apaisement
la règle de droit est tenté de
reconstruire la relation
allons
essayez d'être rationnel essayer de ne
pas créer trop de vagues
essayez de nous baser sur de bons
principes est la meilleure façon de le
faire
cette crise est elle une simple période
de turbulences où un véritable virage
dans la relation canada chine chose
certaine difficile pour le gouvernement
trudeau de faire le moindre progrès tant
que la fermer - joe n'est pas derrière
lui ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa